in this video we will discuss the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system and
before getting into all the complex
stuff let's have an overview of the
system so whenever your blood pressure
falls known as hypotension the kidneys
are able to sense it and they activate
the renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
which acts on kidney as well as the
blood vessels to restore the blood
pressure to the normal most of you know
the kidneys are supplied by a set of
renal arteries which supply almost 20 to
25 percent of whole cardiac output two
kidneys this blood reaches the glomeruli
through the efferent arterioles and
leaves the glomerular through the
afferent arterioles these cells you see
are the juxtaglomerular cells the word
juxta means near and these cells are
located near the glomerulus these cells
secrete a substance known as pro renin
and hypotension is a main stimulator of
converting pro renin into renin renin is
an enzyme which acts on angiotensinogen
the word angio means vessels the word
Tennyson hojin means a substance which
constricts the vessels it is a plasma
protein which is synthesized in the
liver
renin converts angiotensinogen into
angiotensin one the next step takes
place in the lungs when the enzyme
angiotensin converting enzyme acts on
angiotensin 1 and converts it into
angiotensin 2 the angiotensin 2 is a
powerful way so constructor which
mediates the effects of
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
let's look at the effects of angiotensin
2 on blood vessels
as I said angiotensin ii is a very
potent waysto constrictor it constricts
both the arteries as well as the veins
the constriction of the arteries leads
to a total peripheral resistance
increase and the constriction of veins
lead to increase in the venous return to
the heart
both these mechanisms increase the blood
pressure of the person
this effect is rapid and takes a few
minutes now let's look at the effects of
angiotensin ii on the kidneys these
effects are slow and take a few days to
have their maximum effect angiotensin ii
acts on kidney in two ways the first is
the direct mechanism as most of you know
the GFR of the kidney is directly
proportional to the blood flow through
the kidneys the blood enters the
glomerular through the afferent
arterioles and angiotensin ii being a
powerful vaso constrictor constricts
these afferent arterioles mainly and
decreases the blood flow through the
kidneys this results in a decrease in
the GFR of the kidney which results in a
decrease in the urine output through the
kidney now second is the indirect effect
in which the angiotensin ii acts on the
adrenal gland and releases aldosterone
aldosterone in turn acts on the kidney
and increases the sodium reabsorption as
well as the water reabsorption so we
have a decreased urine output increase
in the water reabsorption and increase
in the sodium reabsorption all these
effects lead to an increase in the
extracellular fluid of the body and
increase in the capillary pressure and a
long-term increase in the arterial
pressure
so to summarize let's suppose a person
gets stabbed and he loses a lot of blood
this will lead to a decrease in the
blood pressure of the person known as
hypotension which is a potent trigger of
activation of
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system the
RAS further acts on the blood vessels as
well as the kidneys and normalizes the
blood pressure so this was all about the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
thank you so much for watching this
video like our channel on YouTube for
all the upcoming videos and make sure to
LIKE our channel on Facebook for flash
cards and upcoming notifications